you
sources tell CBS News investigators are
considering searching inside Yellowstone
National Park as they look for two
missing Idaho children Ty Lee Ryan and
Joshua JJ valo
were last seen in September their mother
Laurie valo
was arrested in Hawaii and faces child
abandonment and desertion charges she's
fighting extradition to Idaho
Jonathan Vigliotti reports from Kauai
where she's behind bars as Laurie valo
sits in a Kauai jail cell
sources close to the investigation tells
CBS News detectives are waiting for the
snow to melt in Yellowstone National
Park as they continued the search for
valo 17 year old daughter Ty Lee Ryan
Park officials declined to comment
citing an active investigation according
to court documents Rexburg police said
phone records show ryan visited
Yellowstone with her mother brother JJ
and uncle on September 8th police also
obtained a photo from Laurie bellows
iCloud account of Ty Lee in the park
they say there's been no sign of life
since doorbell camera footage has also
surfaced showing what police believed to
be JJ valo
playing with a neighbor in September
just days before he disappeared this is
a very atypical defendant in a very
unusual case
former Idaho Attorney General David Levy
says Idaho has never seen a case like
this the implication of a parent who
will not cooperate in disclosing their
location is that something very untoward
has happened to these children as
authorities continue to search for any
clues the ex-husband of a Lowe's niece
claims in divorce filings his ex-wife
knows where the children are and was
involved in a cult where numerous
members adults and children alike or
killed off like flies for CBS this
morning
Jonathan Vigliotti kawaii' thank you
just hard to understand why a parent
wouldn't say this is where my children
incomprehensible